hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the appendix to his proma to any
future metaphysics in the last two
sections which are titled a specimen of
a judgment about the critique prior to
its examination which is Count's
response to one of his many critics out
there and then in the final section of
the work which is called proposals as to
an investigation of the critique upon
which a judgment may follow K is going
to provide us some very useful
clarifications and Reflections on how
metaphysics you could say fits in with
also doesn't fit in with the other
sciences and as he's going to call them
branches of knowledge K right and when
we look at what he's using as examples
not all of these really fit the
Criterion for what Kant would like to
call a science a visen shaft but we
we'll just put that aside for the moment
so the first remark that he makes is
sort of a side note as he's responding
to this
critic and he says that other sciences
and branches of knowledge right so what
we're going to talk about here have
their standard and really this should be
plural but what he means here is that
each of them has its own particular
standard it's mashab which quite
literally means like a ruler you know
and if you think about
the derivation of this term this is
similar to the Greek Canon which
originally means something like a
measuring Rod which could also be made
of lead so it can be wound around things
so like a measuring tape and then comes
to mean in later use of the language a
Criterion something that we can use to
make good judgments and so what are the
examples of disciplines let's call them
that he's going to bring up well
mathematics history theology natural
science and medicine jurist prudence and
then even matters of taste which is
something he's going to talk about in
the third critique much later on so how
do these in fact have their standards so
he tells us mathematics has its standard
in itself what does that mean
you can understand that to signify that
mathematics is kind of a self-enclosed
discipline at least with respect to its
main theoretical work obviously it's
applied to things in reality and it
provides a basis for other disciplines
as we're going to see so mathematics is
on really really secure ground and you
we remember Kant talked about pure
mathematics and it's Poss possibility
it's actuality really and how it works
in the uh first part of the uh
promina uh what about history and
theology here's where it gets kind of
interesting history and theology have
their standard their mashab in secular
or sacred
books okay so here God is probably
playing a little bit f fast and
loose uh if we want to think about
history let's put you know um theology
aside for the moment so is history All
About Books Okay history does use books
along with other written documents in
order to assemble together it whatever
picture whatever narrative it provides
us of what has taken place in the past
and I guess you can say that's kind of a
standard you'd like there to be some
written sources but of course even Kant
must have known at that time that
sometimes history might in fact be based
on oral sources and then you write them
down yourself so you know what is
exactly is he saying and then when we
move to theology so this is kind of a
common approach to it it's based on
sacred books the books of he means of
course Christian theology the books of
those things that we call the Bible and
by the way uh Bible is not originally
one single book it is tah in Greek which
means the books plural right a whole set
of writings that have been assembled and
the original Bibles weren't really
codexes they were a bunch of Scrolls
that you'd carry around in a a pouch and
sometimes they'd have more books or less
books you know so this is a little bit
interesting and we don't have too much
time to digress upon this let's come to
another one Natural Science and the Art
of
medicine well what are they based on so
they're based partly on
mathematics but they're also based
partly on as he says experience natural
science is science of the things in the
world that we can in fact perceive or at
least we develop ways of perceiving
things that relate to them right so
that's that's something there medicine
is more of an applied discipline has to
do with the human body perhaps with the
human psyche as well but it does involve
mathematics it involves measuring things
and there's an
experiential side to it as well so
that's its Criterion it's its
standard what about jurist Prudence
jurist Prudence is more like
Theology and history in that as he says
it's B based in books of law so another
kind of book right so we've got secular
books which could include law books I
suppose right uh law books and then
sacred books and then he goes on to talk
about even matters of taste Now isn't
this an interesting Criterion to give in
the examples of the
Ancients did only the Ancients provide
us with criteria for matters of taste K
doesn't believe that but so you know
maybe there's a little bit of rhetoric
going on here what's the main point well
all of these other disciplines all these
other sciences and bodies of knowledge
to whatever degree they actually are
knowledge each of them has its standard
what about metaphysics and here Kant
says something kind of interesting the
standard is yet to be discovered or
found for the Judgment but R of
metaphysics how we should decide what's
real metaphysics and what's just
nonsense or madeup stuff or whatever you
know the things that he call School
metaphysics we don't actually have a
standard but we do have a standard
that's exactly what he's been
articulating in the
proma and in the critique of pure reason
which his critic had reviewed but didn't
sufficiently read according to hun he
says I have made an attempt to determine
it the standard as well as its use what
is to be done then until it be found
when works of this kind have to be
judged if they're of a dogmatic
character then do whatever you like to
no one will play the master over others
here for long if before someone else
appears to deal with him in the same
manner but if they're critical in
character which is what Kant is
proposing and
advancing um then uh not indeed with
reference to other works but to reason
itself the standard of judgment cannot
be assumed but has to be sought for you
can't find it in books or in you know
experiences that we're having or in
applying mathematics or something like
that so that's that's one of the points
that he's making there and moving ahead
several pages in the work we find that
he is going to talk about um these
different types of science once again
and here he notes something really
interesting now it's not a completely
new point but it's getting a little bit
more concrete he's already addressed
this in part three of the
proma mathematics now notice the order
here mathematics natural science laws
arts and then he adds another one even
morality moral right as he says do not
fill the
soul um now what does that actually mean
they don't completely fill the
soul right so they they don't completely
fill up or satisfy we might say to use
the language that we had earlier in the
um
pra right or befen in uh uh the verbal
form no yet in a way or aren't aren't
there guly not
completely and actually for K these
things will never entirely fill the soul
that's why we have metaphysics
metaphysics goes beyond it satisfies a
desire that can be partly satisfied and
addressed by these other bodies of
knowledge or discipline or
Sciences but can't be completely
Satisfied by them so this is really
quite important right he says that there
is a space a real left over for pure and
speculative reason which is what
metaphysics is not just doing using but
also about it's reason applied to itself
and he talks about this as having an
emptiness a an empty space something
that we saw once again discussed in part
three of this which had to do with how
metaphysics is even possible and this
came up in terms of
metaphysics exercise of reason being
able to give to itself and recognize
boundaries grenen right so this is a
very important
idea we we're going to always have to do
metaphysics now if we don't do critical
metaphysics then what's going to happen
he says this emptiness prompts us to
seek in vagaries buffoonery and
mysticism now the terms here are kind of
funny so the the order is actually a
little bit different in the original
German uh fren buffoonery literally
means like making faces grimacing right
uh I say well H how the hell do you do
that in metaphysics well I don't know
you know that's an interesting metaphor
uh vagaries or trifling around uh
tendel fooling around with things that
don't really matter and then the most
interesting term yet because it's going
to appear at the end of this section
mysticism
uhai right now this doesn't just mean
mysticism and Kant doesn't use uh a
cognate term mysticism which he could
have used he uses this other term which
means also
enthusiasm or you know getting worked up
about stuff so it could be mysticism in
the sense of you know a pretension to
like insights that other people don't
have it could also be just like getting
getting yourself all worked up in church
and having the spirit in you or
something like that K is very
distrustful of that why because it has a
completely sub Ive basis and people will
claim to have all sorts of mystical and
metaphysical ecstasies that's another
way of translating schwarm by the way
ecstasy when you know maybe they do but
nobody else can verify it in any way
right so they use that to try to claim
some sort of competence that other
people don't have and so he says the
emptiness of this space prompts us to
seek in vagaries buffoon and mysticism
for what seems to be employment use and
entertainment but which is actually a
mere Pastime undertaken in order to
deaden the Troublesome voice of reason
which in accordance with its nature
requires something that can satisfy it
and does not merely subserve other ends
or the as he's going to put it I love
this phrase interests of our
inclinations
intera n right and if you've read other
works of Kant for example the later on
moral works right the second critique
the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals notice we got metaphysics there
nigan uh inclinations play a major role
not in guiding us rightly but in
actually leading us
astray so when reason doesn't have
something like a critique that H says
he's providing or at least the outlines
of it uh critique of pure reason promina
to any future metaphysics it is going to
inevitably try to satisfy that desire
that it has for something that goes
beyond these other disciplines in ways
that get it in trouble if we wanted to
be a little factious here we could talk
about that old song of looking for love
in all the wrong places reason itself
Kant doesn't talk about love here but
reason itself has a desire has something
that it's seeking out and it's going if
it doesn't find it in the right places
it's going to find it in the wrong
places so Kant is giving us a caution
here and also
clarifying uh how um the use of reason
on itself theoretical and speculative
and pure you could say how that in
metaphysics can go
astray so that's a very interesting
point and then he talks about the
Germans and how you know the Germans can
carry things further than other nations
and you know he said then he says if
this opinion be well-founded then an
opportunity a task presents itself and
you know he's proposing something for
his uh fellow Germans German speakers
right because there is no Germany at the
time as a political entity but uh German
has become a philosophical Language by
this point and so he says well you know
what we can do is carry on something
with metaphysics and then he tells us
something interesting about
metaphysics he says that this science is
of such a special kind b art right in
German that uh it can all at once be
brought to completion which we've seen
him talk a lot about and to that
permanent State Beyond which it can
never be developed it'll it'll reached a
final structure orientation right now
that does that mean that I can't have
any further working out he says no you
can have um you know adornment by
greater clearness in some place or
additional utility but you can actually
finish metaphysics as a system
so this you know there's a side note
people like to joke around about
completing the system of German idealism
well that's part of what Kant was
actually talking about here sketching it
out ahead of time not using exactly
those terms um but it can be brought to
completion and then he says it's got
this advantage that no other science has
or could have not just no other science
has this metap physics is unique in this
way what is it and it lists three
different things that are connected with
each
other none is so completely
isolated uh and independent unending of
others being non-dependent upon what
others provide let's pause on that for a
moment and go back to thinking about
these other things history dependent on
books right secular books um jurist
Prudence depend dependent on law books
mathematics dependent upon itself so
there's a little bit of uh interest
there natural science and medicine
dependent on mathematics and on
experience matters of taste also
dependent presumably on experience but
also the examples of the Ancients
metaphysics is not dependent on any of
these it's only dependent upon itself
which means that it's independent right
and what is the other part exclusively
concerned with the faculty of cognition
pure and simple all of the things are
because they're using the faculty of
cognition but metaphysics is looking at
and if we want to talk about the faculty
of cognition it's really looking at all
the faculties of cognition you know uh
sensibility understanding reason how
these all fit together so that's that's
a unique uh advantage of metaphysics and
then finally he's going to bring this
whole work to a close by talking about
metaphysics and theology what does he
say he talks about a a service a de
which metaphysics performs for theology
making it independent of the Judgment of
dogmatic speculation so meaning that
people can't complain about it or
criticize it because it's engaging in
dogmatic speculation
and securing it completely against the
attack of all such opponents ordinary
metaphysics though it promised theology
much Advantage couldn't keep this
promise the metaphysics that isn't
really metaphysics as a science and by
summoning speculative dogmatics to its
assistance did nothing but arm enemies
against itself and then he brings up
once again mysticism schw right and
again let's remind ourselves it's not
just mysticism in the old classic sense
it is is enthusiasm it is ecstasy it is
this subjective you know I have a
experience that you don't have therefore
I'm better suited to talk about God or
the Angels or pick whatever else you
want right and he says mysticism in a
rationalistic age can prosper only when
it hides itself behind a system of
school metaphysics we're going to get
rid of that stuff through critique and
then there's nowhere to hide this
mysticism in Theology and then he says
it's driven from Theology and now notice
this what it what cons say its last
Hiding Place theology is the place that
mysticism enthusiasm ecstasy can still
hold out until critique comes at it
where's that critique going to happen
well Kant actually has a whole book that
you can read called religion within the
limits of reason alone which tells you
about that I mean it's also there in you
know the first critique and in the
second critique and uh also parts of the
third critique as well but Kant is
engaging in this Enlightenment
rationalistic project of saying we're
not going to do that sort of stuff we're
not going to rely on mysticism or mere
subjective feelings or dogmatic
commitments about religion and then he
says it's driven by driven from its
hiding place by critical
philosophy and so theology or what's
left of it after all the mysticism has
been driven out and
dogmatism will actually be a science for
K like metaphysics can be a science and
it's not going to be like what he was
talking about earlier just this thing
that's dependent on sacred books it's
going to be a rationalistic exercise
thinking about the nature of the
Divine so that's an interesting
transformation and I will close this by
suggesting that so Kant is talking at
the very end about Theology and the
service that metaphysics can perform in
relation to it maybe now Kant doesn't
say this but maybe we could think
of this question would metaphysics a
critical metaphysics the kind that Kant
is advancing perform
similar
services to these other disciplines
history Natural Science medicine jurist
Prudence matters of taste mathematics
morality isn't that what Kant does at
least with some of these in his other
works so this is the end of K proliga to
any future metaphysics we see what
metaphysics is supposed to do in
relation to these other sciences and
bodies of
knowledge